Okay so Michaell here's the tree version, of what I just
said. So remember I draw squares as chance nodes. And so,
chance takes a, chance. And half the time we end up
in a state, where I have, where A has a red card.
And half the time I end up in a state where
A has, or we end up in a state, where A has
a black card. Okay? If A has the black card. Then
B gets to choose whether to hold or not, so let me
add a little bit of color for you since you wanted
some color. This is the place where A gets to make a
decision. Okay. Yep. And then this is the place where B
gets to make a decision. Got it. Okay? So, A is going
to either be in a red state or a black state.
Only A knows this. B does not know this, does not know
what state He is in. And so let's say A is
in a black state. Well, A can only hold in that case.
In part because it makes no sense to resign. And
then B gets to decide whether to resign, and therefore
A gets ten cents or to see, in which case
A gets thirty cents. By contrast, when we're in the
red state A can either hold or resign. If A
resigns he loses 20 cents. If A holds then B
gets to decide whether to resign and which case A
gets 10 cents, or to see the card in which case
A loses 40 cents and B of course gains 40 cents. So this
is just a tree version of what I just wrote. Does that make sense?
>> Okay, yeah I can see how this kind of captures the flow of information but
I feel like there might be a missing
constraint to it. So [INAUDIBLE] I don't know if
there's actually a constraint in this thing but
let me just point out something. And that
is that B has no idea which of
these two states his in, and its hidden information.
>> And because B doesn't know what
states he's in. He doesn't know whether resign over see. In particular B knew
that he was in this left mode state then he would always say see.
If B knew he was always in the rightmost state, then he would always
resign. But he doesn't know which one, so it's not entirely clear what to do.
>> Neat! Where did you get this game? This game is awesome! .
>> I got this game like I got all
of the examples that we're using today, from Andrew Moore.
>> He's clever.
>> He is clever. And
I have shamelessly stolen... All of his examples
and materials for this. But he said it was
okay, by putting up slides in the world and
saying, feel free to steal all of the stuff.
>> You want to write his name so that people can credit him?
>> Yeah, I'm going to write it at the very end. When we talk about.
>> Okay.
>> What we've learned.
>> Awesome.
>> Okay. So here's a question for you Michael. We know that I wrote down
a bunch of words which describe the game, and then I made it a tree,
because I could do that. And it makes it nice and easy
to see what's going on. But now we know, that at least
everything else we've done. We want to make a little matrix. And so
we want to figure out what the value is for different strategies for A
and B. So I'm going to assert, and I think it's pretty
easy to see, I hope. That A basically has only two strategies. Either
A is the type of person that resigns when a card is
read. Or A is the type of person who holds, when a card
is read. Agreed?
>> Interesting, okay. Yeah. Right. So
it really is a conditional policy, right?
It's basically If red hold to resign, if black hold to resign, but your
point is that black isn't really a choice, red is a choice, and
there's only two choices. Okay I can see that as the two strategies sure.
>> Right and of course this does say,
this is, this does kind of say when you're
in the black case you know you're going
to hold. So you know what's going to happen. Ultimately
B can either be the kind of person who resigns,
whenever A holds or chooses to see, whenever A holds. Right?
>> I see so, like in the previous trees. B would have four different
strategies Resigner see in the left state, resigner see in the right state. Here
there's this kind of extra connection, this
sort of a quantum entanglement between these
two states that it, that makes them have to be the same. So there really
is just those two choices.
>> That's exactly right, although, I probably wouldn't have used
the phrase quantum entanglement. But yes, there's an entanglement, certainly.
because we can't tell which state we're in. You're either
going to resign or you're going to see. And you
just don't know what else to do. Okay so A's
a resigner or holder. B's a resigner or a seer.
So the question is what numbers go in this matrix?
And we're going to figure that out by having a quiz.
>> I kind of saw that coming.
>> Mm-hm, do you think you can figure this
out? yeah, yeah. Sure. Sure. Yeah, I think so.
>> Yeah, see, see, see. Yeah, I can
do that. Okay, cool. So, let's go then. Go.